EU energy ministers had today a first
policy debate on the key elements of the
2030 climate and energy framework agreed
by the heads of state in October
ministers concentrated on the governance
aspect of the climate and energy package
more specifically on the most
appropriate indicators to measure the
progress made by member states towards
achieving the targets agreed by EU
leaders Minister stressed also the
importance of completing the internal
energy Market by the end of
2014 the conclusions that we've adopted
today identify priority areas where the
EU should focus its efforts and where
the member states should focus their
efforts for example uh networks
infrastructure projects and particularly
the projects of common interest
crossborder
cooperation and uh cooperation amongst
Regulators as
well and also the involvement of
consumers ministers agreed that having a
truly single market for gas and
electricity is crucial to increase
energy security and Industrial
competitiveness they also acknowledge
the contribution of the energy sector to
the eu's growth strategy which is set
for review next year finally ministers
were briefed by the Italian presidency
and the commission on recent
International Energy
negotiations